the race to replace Nicholas sturgeon as
the Talk of the Town here in Sterling
mine's already focused on who the
runners and Riders could be
there's nobody really is there it's
something older than maybe no
um the finances clip probably I would
say it's maybe just a bit young for to
be the replacement
the painters were preparing a refresh
here at Angus Robertson's office the
government Minister seen by many as
someone who could take the reins the
former deputy leader of the party and
ex-westminster leader others rumored to
run include the finance secretary Kate
Forbes currently on maternity leave
Health secretary Hamza Yusuf is
considering his bed Justice Minister
Keith Brown could be a contender whoever
it is they will face an independence
movement which is stalled we will
continue to set out that Clear Vision of
why we need it and support will continue
to rise but you've now lost the
figurehead of the movement the
independence movement is bigger than any
one person and it's bigger than any one
political party navigating SMP splits on
the Constitution are not the only issues
facing the new first Minister they'll be
forced to tackle the rumbling row over
gender reforms an NHS in crisis public
sector strikes and drug deaths which are
the worst in Europe anybody can stand
with can't remember and all members will
be able to vote and I look forward to a
contest there hasn't been a contested
election for the leadership of the s p
since 2004. whoever replaces Nicola
sturgeon may use this as a chance to
reset could they rip up and start again
the entire strategy that Nicholas
sturgeon has carefully crafted over the
course of her political career and could
this period of change create turbulence
in the smp's Electoral success and allow
their opponents to make gains in ways
they've failed to do for many years
something weighing heavy on a party who
are now deciding the timetable for their
future a contest the SNP did not see
coming Connor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh